[Music]
29:24 Milwaukee it's exciting when there
are multiple teams oh my that's exciting
shoes every night of the season I mean
look there's no way the Kazi could had
any idea was about that benefit a very
solid second game as a blazer for
Carmelo Anthony
[Music]
ten point lead oh man look at this play
bass lines being reversed dumped out
here push me Tolliver on his eyes
shoulder and just recognize that looking
spins back baseline not missing - don't
chatter I promise you that moments only
shooting 42% ago right now
didn't raining devastating
Nana sees a 3-man defensive wall
Yanis right here you talk about that
wall where here's a little Wallbanger
and they made harvey unable to score
thanks to the defense football PES Yanis
your own steps
second half has officially started Yanis
right back where he left off
apologies darkness on this one I mean
it's like
[Music]
backside clear it out and then this one
here man let's try her at the time
defending at us again you imagine
a 42 year old mentally trying to stop
bat out of the gumbo powers it through
yes against [ __ ] tartar
and you're right Carter used to be able
to do the same thing all the time
[Music]
there was defense there was the defense
[Applause]
that's expulsion of is against
and did you see him look offensive on
this end
just that quick you can light the entire
building up
[Applause]
good saying what he just
he ham
one two three four takes it away
hence for heel back for ya - what up man
- out of the gumbo and George Hill
beautiful basketballs first the great
defensive play give me that cp3 get it
early get it back watch that bounce pass
stolen upper from George Hill - then get
out the way it back porch playing
Monster Jam debug I am what's up you
guys if Taylor looks with a B to report
make sure you subscribe for more video
content